the bottom line about China's role is
they've never really been allies of
Putin so much as they have seen
advantage in certain sort of common
positions and they've been perfectly
happy to support Putin rhetorically but
at the same time president XI red put in
the riot act about a knot being so
foolish as to use tactical nuclear
weapons we have seen a willingness to
send dual use Technologies through third
parties in Central Asia but we haven't
seen a willingness to do anything that
would Court sanctions like sending
actual military kit and the Chinese
banking system is trying to disentangle
itself from the Russian one these are
not the signs of a full-throated Ally
what this means is precisely that Putin
is an even weaker position in terms of
his negotiations with the Chinese given
that it may well be that the Chinese end
up emerging as the main Brokers of any
kind of Peace because tough medicine is
something that Putin is more likely to
swallow if it's presented by Beijing
than if it looks as if it's being
imposed by the West